glaubt ihr irgendjemand in der Runde
noch das Putins Atom Drohungen nur ein
also ich will das hoffen dass das so ist
denn alles andere wird alles andere
Katastrophe ich ich muss das hoffen denn
eine weitere Eskalation würde uns eine
fast ausweglose Lage bringen wir könnten
protestieren wir können weitere
Sanktionen auslösen aber mehr wird auch
nicht geschehen ich bin doch ich bin
doch in Ruinen groß geworden und ich
weiß dass die Menschen so ab 60 65
mittlerweile ganz große Furcht dafür
haben dass der Krieg auf uns keine Phase
mehr vom hoffen deswegen frage ich
danach also Herr Hahne bereiten wir uns
tatsächlich im Kopf auf ein Atomkrieg
gerade vor also wir haben auf jeden Fall
Angst und die Frage ist ob die Angst
richtig geschürt worden ist im Sinne von
wir können durch diplomatische Mittel
müssen jetzt alles versuchen oder also
wenn ich so kubikis Partei genossen die
waffenlobbyistin mit dem vierfach-namen
sehe das ist für mich sie eine
Zimmermann ja das ist für mich eine
unzulässige Angstmacherei die zum
Schluss zu einer Geschäftemacher führt
wir müssen noch mehr Waffen und noch
mehr Waffen ich habe von ersten Tag
dieses Angriffskrieges der nämlich ganz
klar ein Angriffskrieg von Putin war
gesagt das löschen darf nicht teurer
sein als der Brand inzwischen erleben
wir dass das Löschen wahrscheinlich
teurer ist weil wir ein Putin jetzt
natürlich geradezu dazu drängen das
wahrzumachen was er kann er könnte auf
den Knopf drücken und ich hoffe Theologe
Christ und bete dass das nicht kommt und
das ist nicht kommt heißt wir brauchen
auch in Deutschland deswegen bin ich
sehr dankbar dass Olaf Scholz sehr
zurückhaltend ist bei dieser waffenfrage
von vornherein wir brauchen Gespräche
wir brauchen Diplomatie wir müssen jeden
Faden Nutzen zu Putin Herr Söder hat
sich doch gebrüstet als er als
Ministerpräsident als erstes zu Putin
vor der große Putin wo bleiben denn
diese Leute jetzt darf ich dich mal
bitte ich darf das hier so nicht stehen
lassen jeder jeder weiß dass ich auch in
der die Frage in etwas dezilitere
Haltung habe als Marie angestrakt
Zimmermann aber ihre Haltung ist
nachvollziehbar sie ist konsequent und
sie wird auch von vielen Menschen
geteilt von mir nicht weil ich auch
finde wir müssen aufpassen bei
Waffenlieferung wir müssen Ukraine
helfen deshalb ist die Rück
Zurückhaltung bei Leopard 2 Panzern
angemessen aber bisher müssen wir die
Ukraine mit Waffen versorgen um sich
selbst zu verteidigen gegen einen
ergressor der völkerrechtswillig handelt
und das ist ein Unterstützung die
völkerrechtliche legitim ist noch einmal
geboren sie stützen die Waffenlieferung
die der Kanzler eben auch in die Ukraine
befürwortet jetzt hören wir von Herrn
Hahne das ist teilweise Kriegstreiberei
was außerdem in der Koalition Frau
Zimmermann spricht der hane an passiert
ich habe gefragt bei den Atom Drohungen
Putins ob wir tatsächlich noch glauben
dass das nur ein Bluff ist was antworten
Sie nicht was sie hoffen sondern was sie
was sie glauben womit Sie rechnen
ich rechne damit dass wir zuversichtlich
sein dürfen weil auch Putin nicht in
selbstmörderischer Absicht unterwegs ist
das würde ich immer unterstellen nein
ich finde es ist ganz wichtig dass das
ernst genommen wird von uns und unsere
Bundesregierung nimmt das auch ernst
aber ich unterstütze das was Herr hane
gesagt hat und da haben wir genau wie
auch mit wie auch Wolfgang Kubicki
durchaus ein Konflikt mit eigenen Streik
Zimmermann ich befürworte die
Waffenlieferung wir haben es übrigens
als Deutscher Bundestag beschlossen
selbstverständlich ganz verstanden
darf der Bundestag hat beschlossen dass
wir selbstverständlich und es ist ein
Wechsel in der Sichtweise einer
Bundesregierung wir liefern Waffen in
Krisengebieten in Kriegsgebiete das
haben wir nie getan und jetzt tun wir es
und das ist richtig damit sich die
Ukraine selbst verteidigen kann aber es
ist eben ein Unterschied welche Waffen
man liefert ob es Verteidigungswaffen
sind die liefern wir international
abgestimmt und die Leopard 2 Panzer
gehören nicht dazu jedenfalls bis nicht
weil das auf internationale Ebene so
gesehen wird ich habe es noch nicht ganz
verstanden was sie mit Putins Atom
Drohung anfangen wenn der droht und das
hat er vielfach getan und hatte andere
Drohungen immer wahr gemacht dann müssen
wir doch im Kopf damit rechnen dass er
das umsetzt dann müssen wir doch im
Moment im Kopf überlegen was machen wir
eigentlich wenn der ja ein Atomschlag
macht also glauben Sie mir ich bin ganz
fest davon überzeugt dass diese
Bundesregierung alles Szenarien
durchspielt das ist ihr verdammter Job
und das wird sie auch tun trotzdem ist
es klug wenn uns nicht einfach gelähmt
vor Angst die Beine schlottern sondern
wenn wir vernunftbegabt bleiben und das
tun wir indem wir eben nur international
abgestimmt Waffen liefern indem wir
keine Alleingänge machen und in dem das
halt Olaf Scholz ja auch wieder deutlich
gemacht er hat ja mit Putin telefoniert
das wurde übrigens kritisiert ich finde
es richtig auch wenn im Moment
aber gar nicht gesprächsbereit aber das
ist ja immer wieder versuchen und das
finde ich richtig und diese
Bundesregierung steht auf jeden Fall wir
liebe Frau Hagedorn können uns ja nicht
wehren nachdem
CDU und CSU Verteidigungsminister die
Bundeswehr zugrunde gerichtet haben
durch lange bevor es die Ampel gab das
muss doch alles auf den Tisch das heißt
aus einer bestimmten politischen
Situation
wir sind in einer Lage und ich will an
den einen Begriff erinnern den sie finde
ich Ihnen sehr fahrlässiger Weise
genannt haben Geschäftemacherei es war
keine Frage der Geschäftemacherei am
Beginn dieser Auseinandersetzung hier
hat am 24 Februar Vladimir Putin unter
völliger Missachtung des Völkerrechts
ein freies Land überfallen da ging es
bei der Frage von Waffenlieferungen
nicht um die Frage von Geschäfte
macherei davon war die Bundesregierung
weit entfernt ich spreche ist genauso
aber sind Begriffe die in einer Weise
Dinge anraunen die hoch gefährlich ist
es ging damals und wir müssen
mittlerweile diesen Krieg historisieren
wir so einer völlig neuen
hochgefährlichen Phase da sind wir ja
alle einer Meinung die Atomfrage ist
dramatisch aber wenn wir ehrlich sind
wenn sie mit ihrer Position der nicht
Lieferung von Waffen übrigens auch nicht
der nicht die Form von Waffen die
bereits die Amerikaner längst getätigt
habe ich nie gesagt dass ich für die
Nummer ist ja gut dann war das
jedenfalls Erklärung bedürftig weil der
Begriff der Geschäfte macherei lässt
Dinge anklingen die manche
des löschen ist mittlerweile teurer aber
das müsste man erklären das musste man
erklären es war so unklar dass ich es
klären am Anfang wenn am Anfang nicht
Waffen geliefert worden wären und ganz
klar zu sagen dann stünde heute Putin an
der polnischen Grenze das müssen wir uns
bewusst machen es war also von daher die
Verteidigungsfähigkeit der Ukraine die
überhaupt verhindert hat dass dieser von
Putin erwartete gloriose Sieg völlig in
die Hose gegangen ist aber und jetzt
kommen wir zum zweiten Abschnitt wir
haben eine Wende in der Zeitenwende
die annexionspolitik durch Putin bei
gleichzeitiger Teilmobilmachung die zum
Teil und das würde ich auch kritisieren
zum Teil durchaus triumphfallistisch am
ersten Augenblick gefeiert wurden auch
in hiesigen Breiten ist ein völliger
falsche Einschätzung gewesen weil dieser
triumphialismus Putin zeigt Schwäche in
der Tat er hat sie ungemein gezeigt er
hat mich mit der teilmobil machen den
Krieg ins eigene Land getragen
mittlerweile wissen auch die Menschen in
Moskau und St Petersburg was die Stunde
geschlagen es sind nicht nur noch die
Menschen aus buchiatien und anderen
Regionen in den Krieg nein es sind alle